cyril ne regarde rarement les films
d'ailleurs il sert pas partir il regarde
rarement les films on a l'idée on a
l'idée était de rendre toujours de lui
résumer pour faire genre devant les
actes
source chroniqueur anonyme bernard
montiel est un bâtard
c'est toi maintenant alors oui c'est
beinheim non c'est pas moi non
sincèrement c'est pas moi de leur beau
dire du mal de vous
jamais un à ne jamais jamais d'abord
est-ce que vous confirmez la falaise et
déjà alors il ya déjà des habitants qui
viennent pour des films comme ça des
parements idem pour les livres si par
hasard vous les lisez pas et même les
films de vos potes et les pièces de
théâtre mais aussi la belle nous coûtait
rien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]